looking at the last piece here which is
a way of diagrammatically visually
graphically representing a database okay
particularly a relational database okay
so this is called it's got two names
it's called a database schema that's the
main word you hear for its schema you
can hear the word schematic that comes
out of that right schematic diagram
occasionally you'll hear it called an ER
D which is an entity relationship
diagram and the reason why it's called
that is because it's filled with
entities and relationships but I'll show
you that in a second so here it is
remember we said the basic building
blocks of a relational database are two
of them number one you've got tables
right and your tables have fields and
then these fields are related to other
fields in other tables so how do we show
that well a nice simple way of doing it
is by saying take each table and let's
make a rectangle out of it I'll show you
I mean so for instance student okay
underneath the name of your table you
list all the fields that you know about
it okay so for instance you might say
first name last name class ID for
instance and let's say date of birth
okay that's that's a pretty typical set
of fields that you would know about a
student and then you put it in a box
like this okay but this table doesn't
sit on its own it's a relational
database it might be related to for
instance a class table okay excuse me
so what kinds of things might you know
about a class well you'll know it's ID
its name right that class ID that class
sorry I might have a teacher associated
with it
and maybe you know its location so you
might say broom okay now what you can
see here is that I've got some our
primary keys and foreign keys happening
here right in the class table in this
table a class ID is what kind of key is
it I think it's a primary key right it's
a unique identifier every class will
have a different class ID okay so you've
got a key here which appears in another
table so class ID student dog class ID
is a foreign key class class ID is a
primary key okay because they're linked
I'll put a link like that now um
sometimes you also be asked to describe
the nature of this relationship here
so it's either one-to-one one-to-many or
many too many so you have a think about
it which one isn't let's just imagine
we're in a primary school okay
primary school how many classes does a
student have in a primary school in a
primary school you just have the one
right you're like I'm in 6c right and
you might in that class for all year
okay so a student has one class now you
ask the question from the other way
around how many students does a class
have the answer is a class has many
students right whatever kind of class
you've got so this is going to be one to
many okay one two minute so you'd put
the many here and the one up here okay
one class has many students and a
student only has one class okay all
right now this is just for the sake of
it let's put one more table on here okay
which is probably the most natural one
is a teacher okay what kinds of things
make you know about the teacher well I
guess they'd had their own ID you know
for instance in this school we make
three-letter codes out of every
teacher's name right and they have to
not overlap so I mean my
mine's easy because my surname is two
letters okay but you've got other
teachers in the school for instance we
have a mr. Kowalski and a mrs. Kowalski
okay so mrs. Kowalski was here at the
school first so she got the teacher ID k
o w first three letters of her name but
mr. Kowalski arrived later right so he
couldn't take care of W because that
would make this no longer our primary
key does that make sense so that's why
does anyone have mr. korsky as the
teacher yeah okay so you guys know his
Cody is yeah total knockout which is
that's a great actually that's a great
name right well because T is the first
letter is n right so you have to pick
these fields in order to make sure that
you can still sort with them got a
teacher ID are you might have things
like say the subject if they teach all I
just broke down that's a secondary
school anyway maybe you know their
address you get that or you wouldn't
know their address the school would know
their address okay so there's our table
okay and you can see again you've got
this relationship happening okay and
it's going to be the same kind of
relationship that you had watching
though here it's a bit different isn't
it because I said you know we're talking
about a on a primary school right how
many classes does a teacher teach in a
primary school answer one they just take
care of one class right and in the same
way the class all in their one teacher
so this would be one to one okay so
that's a database schema and you can see
what's it filled with it's filled with
the entities that's the names of the
tables and it's also got the
relationships between those entities
okay hence entity relationship diagram
now you'll be asked to draw these quite
a lot or sometimes you'll get one given
to you and you might need to fill in the
nature of the relationships or fill in
some of the tables that are missing or
maybe add in a table that isn't there
but would help okay so that's how you
draw a database schema